MALE SPEAKER: So wow.
How great is this?
It is my enormous pleasure
today to introduce
Bob Ryan, author of
"Scribe, My Life in Sports."
He's a Jersey kid who
made Boston his home
and went on to cover
sports here, nationally
and around the world, playoffs
and championships in virtually
every college and pro
sport plus the Olympics.
He's been writing about
sports, based on his book,
pretty much since he could
pick up a pen and pencil
and had some paper
in front of him--
professionally, since
1968, until his retirement
a couple of years ago.
Bob spent almost his entire
career working for the "Globe"
with a couple of years out
working on air for Channel 5.
But even if you never
heard his voice on the air,
you certainly heard it through
his writing-- sometimes blunt,
sometimes flowery, always
opinionated and to the point.
I'm a lifelong sports fan
myself, and reading Bob's work
has been one of the high
points of every one of my days
since I moved to
Boston in the '70s.
Please join me in welcoming
the one and only Bob Ryan.
[APPLAUSE]
BOB RYAN: Well thank you.
Thank you for coming.
And on behalf of me,
I want to thank me
for allowing you to play hooky.
[LAUGHTER]
BOB RYAN: We're obviously
going to get to questions,
but I'll throw out
some opening remarks.
One of the questions-- the
book has been out for a week.
A week ago today was
the publication date.
I felt like it had a very
long gestation period
because the book was
actually-- the send button
on the original draft was
hit on August 27, 2013.
And at that point, I assumed
it would be a spring release.
And that would have been good,
but any author will tell you he
or she is very
happy to have a fall
release with the
holidays coming up.
So in that sense,
I was very grateful
that there was some
sort of procrastination.
But by the time
the book came out,
I felt like I had had
the book by c-section.
It was a long wait, and
I was anxious to have it.
And so that's the genesis there.
One of the things I've
been asked this week--
and I've done a lot of radio
interviews, which is very, very
nice-- is why did you
decide to write the book?
The actual truth is-- and
I'm not being disingenuous
when I say this.
So of course, all along
the way in my career
I thought about writing a book.
I think any author
or writer with an ego
and a little hint
of pomposity thinks
that maybe the world
would just love
to know all his or her thoughts
about the career they've led.
But I talked myself out of it.
I really did, because I
just came to the conclusion,
you're flattering yourself.
Better people than you have
either not written books
or have written
books that didn't
seem to have much traction.
So that's a nice thought,
but put it aside.
Then about four
years ago, an agent
named Andrew Blowner, who was
a Brown University graduate who
had read during the Bird
era, and had read me then
and is a big basketball
fan, a New Yorker,
born and raised in
Manhattan, came to me
and identified himself-- he's a
very prominent agent for people
far beyond sports--
and came to me
and identified himself
as a fan of my work
and said that he really
thought I should do a book.
And I explained to him that
I'd already talked myself
out of doing a book,
but he persuaded me
that there was some viability.
I said, OK.
I said, that's great,
I appreciate that.
But I'm not going to do
anything until I am free
and I'm officially retired.
I want to be able to
concentrate on this,
and I'm planning on getting
out after the London Olympics.
So if you can sit around
and wait for me to get done,
then we'll talk.
And he was very patient.
And we had a couple of meetings.
Lunches.
Meetings-- we had lunches
and a few beers in New York
and in Boston over the years.
And when I did get freed up
after the London Olympics
and officially retired from the
"Globe" on a day-to-day basis,
we got together.
I got up a little proposal,
he shopped it around,
and in January of
2013, an editor
in New York City named
George Gibson from Bloomsbury
took the book.
It was really fortuitous
because George Gibson
and I had worked together 25
years ago on a previous book,
a Celtics book that some of
you might even be aware of
or have seen.
I can't even remember the
long, pretentious title,
but it was about the
images-- iconic--
but it was all about pictures.
Great photos from a tremendous
photographer, the late Dick
Raphael, and I could
supply the text.
It was much more of a picture
book first and a print book
second.
There is plenty of
print, but the pictures
were the selling point.
But George had edited that book.
He worked up at Addison-Wesley
in Reading at that time,
and we had no contact
in the ensuing years.
None.
Now, he has taken the book.
So I'm in the hands of two
people that believe in me,
and believe me, as much or
more than I do in myself
with regard to this project.
I wrote the book over the months
of April to August of 2013
after about a six week period
of actually researching myself.
I had to go back and check out
things and corroborate memories
and check facts and
remind myself of things.
And it was very interesting.
It was kind of fun.
And then I got started writing
and for the first time--
I'd written 11 previous
books and all them,
of course, as I was a full-time
employee of the "Globe."
And the other books
all have to be
crammed in on nights and
weekends and vacations.
And it's like a giant term
paper hanging over your head.
That's exactly what it's like.
And they're not fun.
And only a couple of them
really involved a process
that was even
remotely pleasurable.
Any author will tell you that
the most time-- the great line
that was uttered-- I
don't know who said it.
Someone, one of you
here, you might know.
Someone is credited with
saying, "I don't like writing.
I like having written."
And most authors of any
kind will relate to that.
This book was not
hard to write in
that this was one of the
few times it didn't feel
as if were a giant term paper.
One reason being
I was going to be
able to devote my
full energies to it.
I actually wrote on a schedule.
I read about, what
does John Updike do?
What does Philip Roth do?
What does Grisham and King do?
What do they do?
They actually sit down
and write on a schedule.
That's what they do.
They get up in the morning,
they have breakfast, they write.
They have lunch, they
go back, they write.
Then they go on about
their merry way.
Never did that before.
So I arranged a
schedule for myself.
Four days a week writing, and
one day a week that I called
Make Money Monday.
Now, that was through my
"ESPN, Around the Horn,"
if you're familiar with
that, and maybe my Comcast,
which is the studio
up in Burlington.
That's where I do
the Comcast at night.
I tried to consolidate
them as often as possible
to have one day where I
could-- and which I do often,
by the way, because
of the logistics.
I live 40 miles one
way from Burlington.
It's a shlep, believe me.
I get sick of 128.
I hate it.
I'm so sick of looking at it,
and I can't get rid of it.
So I had Make Money Monday.
And then I wrote Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday,
and the occasional Saturday
when my wife was out of town.
And I actually stuck to it.
It was the first time
I had ever exhibited
any kind of discipline.
And not only that, I
actually beat the deadline.
Now, nobody does that, and I
certainly had never done that.
But the actual deadline--
deadlines, they
give you a deadline and
it's like a speed limit.
If the speed limit's 65, we
know you can go 70 safely.
And you get a deadline
in print at a publisher--
they'll give you a
deadline, and they
know it's going to be
at least a month later.
They know that.
They build it in.
It's like flight times.
I actually made it because I had
a self-imposed deadline, which
was September 1, due to the
fact that my wife and I have
an annual little
trek up to Maine.
And I wanted to go up there
with a clear mind and feeling
good about myself
and no pressure.
So I did it.
I got it done.
I was amazed.
I surprised myself.
Now, of course, the editing
process takes place from that.
And George Gibson is
a phenomenal editor.
Brilliant guy.
And he was able to help
me shape-- take this
from that original chapter
and put it in that chapter.
And without rearranging
or writing any new words,
I was able to
re-craft the book--
he was able to help me shape
the book into a coherent book.
It is, as you'll see, it is
not a chronological book.
It wasn't intended to be.
I never wanted it to be.
It wasn't going to be a book--
I was born on February 21,
1946 and then right up to today.
No, it's a thematic book.
I thought I would break it
up into different experiences
in sports that I've covered,
and so it's a thematic book.
And it also has several
personality profiles
of prominent Celtics such
as-- or Celtic-oriented people
such as Red Auerbach, Dave
Cowens, Larry Bird, and John
Havlicek; a chapter
on Chuck Daly, who
I had a very interesting and fun
relationship with from the time
he was at BC 45 years
ago; and Bob Knight.
I mean, you can't go wrong
writing about Bob Knight.
Everybody's fascinated
about Bob Knight.
And so I had my own particular
interesting up and down,
up the graph, down the graph
experience with Knight.
And I was able to
write about him.
But George was able to craft
this so that the first half is
essentially, basically,
kind of chronological.
It takes me from birth to--
and the column-- it takes me
from birth to the end of the
'87, '88 Celtics season when
I-- it was the
last time I covered
the team on a daily basis.
In '89, I became a
full time columnist
and spent the last 25 years
of my career writing columns,
and then several features
too, which I think
are important to do.
So the second half of the book
is more thematic-- chapter
on football,
chapter on colleges,
chapter on my life with
television, both local
and ESPN, chapter
on golf, et cetera,
et cetera, international
basketball, the Olympics.
And then tying it all together
with a little personal
look back about everything.
And talking about my
father, which is something
I'd never done
before, and it was
very-- he died when I was 11.
And this was really
almost-- I won't go so far
as to say cathartic, but
it was more emotional
than I expected it
was going to be.
So that's the logistics, if
you have the remotest interest
in how this thing
was put together.
The career, I'm proud
of in the sense of I
really did have two
distinct halves.
The first half was with a strong
identity covering the Celtics.
And I was very proud of that.
And I loved it.
I say in the book that if
I could turn the clock back
to January 1, 1980 and
to January, 31, 1989,
professionally I'd
change nothing.
The good, the bad,
the in between,
I'd do it all over again.
And I might even backdate
it to January 1, 1970.
That's how much I
enjoyed that aspect
of covering the NBA--
being a beat man,
traveling with the
NBA essentially.
Also there was a year
of covering the Red Sox.
A full year, '77.
And that's a story
you'll find out.
I was in between Peter
Gammons's stints at the "Globe."
So the second half is more
thematic and that's the deal.
The highlight of the second
half, which I [INAUDIBLE],
is getting involved
in the Olympics.
Now, that's something
that-- though growing up I
had an interest in
reading about the Olympics
as far back as the '56
Olympics, reading about them
in "Sports Illustrated,"
I never associated myself
with covering them or
thought that I would.
I never gave it a
whole lot of thought.
And when I stumbled
into them in '92,
when I went to
cover the Dream Team
and did a couple of
other pieces in addition
to the basketball pieces,
and fell in love with them--
I love the Olympics.
When they're somewhere
else-- we'll get to that.
I know you're
going to ask what I
think about Boston
and the Olympics.
I mean, at least,
I think you would.
So I love the Olympics.
I went to eleven
of them in a row.
And six were
summer, five winter.
And they provided me with a
whole different perspective,
so valuable.
I used to look forward
to getting away
from our meat and potatoes
stuff in the middle of winter
for three weeks, going
somewhere, hopefully
going somewhere other
than-- Salt Lake was good,
but you want to go
somewhere with the Olympics.
You want to get
out of the country
and go somewhere
and immerse yourself
in the entire experience,
come home kind of refreshed
and jump back into
your regular routine.
And the same in the summer.
And it was a great way to break
up the winter and the summer
in those Olympics.
I really did fall in
love with the Olympics,
and there's quite a bit
about the Olympics in there.
So with that said,
I'm hoping now
you might have some questions,
whether it's about the book,
whether it's about
sports, whether it's
about the newspapers, whatever.
I'm at your disposal.
To anybody.
AUDIENCE: We live in an instant
gratification society, right?
And even on your "Around
the Horn" experience,
you have 30 seconds to make
your point or less, right?
How do you think that that
has changed and will continue
to change the profession
of journalism and writing?
And what are writers
going to have
to do in order to keep
future generations engaged
to the point that they want
to read a 200 page book?
BOB RYAN: Oh boy.
Thanks.
I'll start with the first
one before I can figure out
how I can babble my way
through the second one.
One of the things
that's happened-- and we
have certain culprits,
starting with talk radio--
is the lack of
perspective and the demand
for instance adjudication,
instant judgment,
instant assessment
on everything.
And it's certainly
not a good thing.
Consider that in 1979, when
the first all 24-hour talk
radio devoted to sports
was WFAN, and that now,
35 years later, that is
the number one radio format
in America.
It has surpassed country,
which was the previous holder.
There are more stations devoted
to sports talk radio in America
than any other format,
which is stunning.
In any big market there
are multiple stations.
We have a great example here.
We finally had a competitor
that challenged WEEI.
Sports Hub 98.5 has done
that, and now they're
fighting back and forth
over supremacy now.
And they probably
will for a long time.
One of the things that sports
radio has proven, sadly--
and hosts have to
acknowledge it--
is that good is boring
and bad has sizzle.
Negativity trumps positivity
by about a 10 to 1 margin.
When a team is going
well, the calls
are repetitive and frequent, but
when things aren't going well,
stand back.
We had exhibit A here
after the Kansas City
game with the Patriots.
And Brady's fate,
and the team's fate,
and I mean there's
nothing illegal about it.
We had reasons to
doubt them, and I did.
I wanted to see them
assemble an offensive line.
We'll look into that later.
Point being, it's back
to the point here.
Perspective has been lost.
One sport that has
really suffered from it
is baseball, because
baseball, with 162 games,
you can have long lulls.
You can have 10-game losing
streaks and win a pennant.
The best hitter is going to go
0 for 4 with three strikeouts.
The best pitcher--
Clayton Kershaw anybody?
The best pitcher can get
lit up on certain occasions.
That's the nature of the game.
Baseball is not meant to be
micromanaged on a daily basis.
It's meant to be looked at
with a little step back,
whether it's a series
or a week or month,
and then we can make
some proper judgments,
because there's so
many things that
go into the ebb and
flow of baseball season.
Football, OK, once a week.
There are only 16 games.
It's totally understandable
that a football game
is completely micromanaged
when there are only 16 of them.
And therefore, if everyone has
a disproportionate importance
compared to 1 out of 162.
That's kind of obvious.
And the same goes for
basketball and hockey.
You need a little
bit of perspective.
That's been lost.
And it's not encouraged anymore.
And writers get
swept up into it too.
And so that's kind of
answering your question.
That's one of the
negative by-products
of where we are-- the focus
on the day-to-day heat
intensity of sports interest.
Now, technology-- and we
might as well get right to it.
I mean, here I am at Google.
Technology has been
a two edged sword.
Technology made my life a
lot easier in so many ways
than writing a story,
sending a story.
Writing this book, for
the first time, because it
was the first book-- I hadn't
written a book in ten years.
So it was the first
post-iPad era for me.
The first post-iPhone era
for me with writing a book.
And in contrast to
all those other books,
going back to 1972 when
I wrote my first one,
the process was enhanced by
that little baby right there.
Whenever I needed a fact
or a spelling or whatever,
a stat-- bingada, bingada,
bingada-- right there.
I loved that.
It was fantastic, and
it made my life easy.
It's hard to imagine going
back 40 years on a typewriter
with carbon copy
and hoping, if you
needed to find out something
and it wasn't instantly
available in an encyclopedia,
making a phone call
and maybe two days later
you get the information.
That's where we were, writing
stories in those days.
Now you have the instant
gratification of that.
You used the word gratification.
Yeah, instant
gratification is demanded.
And it's very dangerous.
I do think what we
went through here
could be a mini course
in a journalism school,
to look at how Boston reacted to
the first four games of the New
England Patriots season.
And I was guilty.
I was asked on the
air, on Comcast.
Somebody might have even see it.
After the Cincinnati
game-- how do
you think they're going to do?
I said, they'll
be seven and nine.
And that's because I had
no-- my mind couldn't wrap
around the idea that
they could reconstruct
that offensive line,
it was such a mess.
And they did it in
five nights, five days.
I don't know how they did it.
I still don't know
how they did it.
And suddenly with a line,
Brady's Brady again.
Isn't that nice?
So there's a lot more
of this aspects of this
that we could talk
about, but I just
think that the ability to step
back and accept that there
is an ebb and flow-- but I said
that the biggest sport casually
in this is baseball.
It's absolutely baseball,
because baseball
with 162 games, it just
should not be micromanaged.
Years ago, I suggested,
knowing it would never be done,
but I really thought
it was the way to go.
I really suggested
to my sports editor
that rather than cover
every game with a game story
that we should
cover it by series.
You should wait and you
should provide information
about what happened in
the bare bones-- let's
say you have a three-game
series Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
Friday and Saturday and
Sunday, you go to the game,
you assess all the information.
Monday you have
an overview piece
about the weekend-- a series.
But nobody's going to do that.
Now, we have changed the
nature of game stories.
And they're being phased out.
But not to the full
extent that anybody
would dare do what
I suggest and wait
until the series is
over in baseball.
And then weigh in on the import
and the reality of the weekend,
but I think it would
be a great idea.
Baseball.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you've seen
a lot of incredible games
over your career
and over your life.
If you could go back
and relive one game,
what's the greatest
game or series
that you've ever
personally witnessed?
BOB RYAN: I'd have
to go by sport.
I really do.
I can't pick one.
I have to go by sport.
I am associated with
basketball more than anything
and then maybe baseball.
But it's just so hard.
And then within
basketball, there's the NBA
and there's college.
And I went to 29 Final Fours
and lots of tournament games.
I loved March.
I used to try to cover-- get
out there and be somewhere
for the entire month when I
was covering the tournament.
But I have a fairly reasonable
answer for sport by sport.
For football, the easiest one
by far, it's the snow game.
It's the last game
in the stadium,
it's the Tuck Rule Game.
And I immediately
decried the Tuck Rule
was an abomination
under the Lord.
And it's finally
been adjudicated,
but it benefited us.
And I didn't mind
it as much, though,
even though it was an
abomination under the Lord,
that it was divine retribution
for Sugar Bear Hamilton and Ben
Dreith in 1976.
And I was there for that
in the Oakland Coliseum,
as it was known then, OK?
So you know the one
I'm talking about.
And they were the
best team in football,
as I realized that day.
And they got
screwed by the refs,
and they didn't win in '76.
So 25 years later, we finally
got divine retribution.
Now we're even with Oakland, OK?
But it's a bad rule,
and they got rid of.
A fumble-- fact.
I'm going to just
digress very briefly.
Because one of the things
in sports that absolutely
I am most mystified by,
and I pose this question
and never get an answer.
At what point in
football history
did down by contact
come into play?
Because I guarantee you,
in the '50s and '60s,
we knew a fumble when
we saw it, and you
could fumble when that
ball hit the ground.
Well, I don't know when they
put it in, but that's the rule.
It takes weight off the
referees, of course,
makes it easy.
Now with replay they can get
it right every single time,
because they can-- but
a fumble's a fumble.
To me, a fumble should
be a ball is loose.
When the ball was
loose, the whistle
doesn't blow until
somebody gets it.
Now, if in the course
of trying to get it,
you observe someone is
guilty of a little bit
too extra enthusiasm, like
a knee in somebody's [GRUNT]
or an elbow in their
nose, OK, you call it.
You drop the flag, give them
15, even if they get it.
But why don't
they-- I hate that.
OK.
Now, so the tuck-- Vinatieri's
field goal in the snow.
If not the greatest field goal
ever, it's one of the two,
because Pat Summerall kicked a
very similar one for the Giants
in '58 that everybody in my
area-- I grew up in Jersey--
will remember.
OK, that game.
The import of it
was [INAUDIBLE].
That was my football moment.
Basketball.
The triple overtime game with
Phoenix in '76 still for me
resonates.
There's so much
drama in that game.
The Celtics played
the best they had
played in the entire playoffs
in the first 14 minutes
of that game.
They got up by 22.
Phoenix would not go away.
No matter what they did, they
could not get them to go away.
And they finally come
back and tied it up,
and we had this historic
three overtimes, including
John Havlicek's miracle shot,
followed by Gar Heard's miracle
shot, followed by Ritchie
Powers, a referee,
getting attacked at
mid court by a fan
after the end of
overtime, the time out
that Silas called that
Ritchie Powers wouldn't call.
And then finally Glenn McDonnell
coming deep, deep, deep, deep
off the bench to win
the game for them
in this third overtime.
That was my-- and then with
Bird, there's a ten way tie.
You know, Bird era.
Come on.
But
the Heat game.
You know, the game with the
97 degree Fahrenheit on Friday
night.
May 8, 1954.
May 6.
Or not May.
June 6, 1984.
Game five.
That was a mind over
matter such as I've never
seen because--
we'll get to that.
But that game, and game
six in '86 against Houston,
which was Bird's own choice,
you'll read in the book,
as his favorite game because
he was "never more prepared."
Isn't that interesting?
Why would he say that? "Never
more prepared" for a game.
If you remember, game five
was the Sichting-Ralph Sampson
fight.
And it was a lot of emotion
attached to that series
as we came home.
And Larry assured the
fans via the media,
as he did so well in those days,
everything's going to be OK.
It was his version of
Aaron Rodgers's R-E-L-A-X.
It was OK back in '86.
Then he went out
and played the best
all around game I
ever saw him play.
He was in every
aspect of the game,
including defense--
he was phenomenal.
He was everywhere.
OK.
Baseball.
It isn't one game.
It's the totality of games
four and five and eight in '04.
They've lost game three 19 to 8.
We've all buried them.
I wrote-- I killed them.
And we had to.
I said, you wanted the Yankees?
You've got the Red Sox.
You happy now?
Et cetera, et cetera.
So we know how that one
went in ninth inning.
And the walk, the
steal, the single.
Then we get around.
Papi hits a game-winning homer.
The next night--
oh, and excuse me.
Later that day-- see, the
games ended on the same day,
because the first went
into after midnight,
and the next one
started at 5:00 PM.
So game five starts at 5:00
PM here, goes extra innings,
and the moment when
Wakefield comes in--
remember the history of
Wakefield the year before.
And Wakefield comes
in and guy gets on it.
And Varitek's catching.
And of course, he
didn't catch him.
It was the other
guy who caught him.
And he wild pitches him
around to third base.
And we're ready
for the next one.
And he finally strikes out
Ruben Sierra [INAUDIBLE] inning
and then Papi on a
ten pitch at bat.
Bloops one to center off
Loaiza to win the game.
The totality of the
emotional experience
of those two and the whole thing
was my favorite baseball moment
as a writer.
As a fan, October
1, '67 still stands
as a culmination of a fan
experience for so many of us
that year that it still
is kind of over there.
And finally hockey,
though not my sport,
I got on that moving
train in '11, 2011,
after the second series.
Covered the Tampa Bay series
and covered the finals,
and that seventh game
against the Lightning, 1-0.
No penalties.
And the coach,
their coach, Boucher
saying that it was like
60 minutes of overtime.
And it was.
It was tension-filled
beyond belief.
And then going out to Vancouver,
getting down 0-2, finally
winning and being there.
So the game was
that overtime game,
but the Phoenix-- not
[INAUDIBLE], that 1-0 game.
But the whole
experience was-- you
know, that enabled me to be
able to say I'd covered all four
major championships, which is
something not everybody gets
to do.
And I actually had covered
all four major championships,
in a seven year period too.
College basketball--
I'll go one more.
Villanova-Georgetown
in kind of tie
for first between
Villanova-Georgetown
in '85 and Duke-Kentucky.
The 104-103 game.
The Laettner shot.
Because that is
generally acclaimed
to be the best college
game ever played,
and I would certainly concur.
Certainly the best
one I ever saw.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So, Bob, I often
listen to Bill Belichick answer
questions.
And it's extremely painful.
BOB RYAN: I want to [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I'm curious.
If he's not the most frustrating
athlete/coach to cover,
who might be?
BOB RYAN: No, he is
for the beat people.
And there's a big distinction
between how the beat
people react to him and how
the columnists react to him.
The beat people are
so totally frustrated.
They need information.
They need to know that
it was-- could you
be more specific than
a lower body injury?
Could you be more specific
than that, you know?
They need to know things and
they need a lot of things
that they can't get from him.
However, there is
a misconception
that he is always that way.
He is not always that way.
He is often that way.
He's horrible on
Sunday after the game.
I really mean he
shouldn't even bother.
Don't even bring him out
there, because win or lose,
he's monotone and it's useless.
He's a little bit
better on Monday
after he's seen
the film, the tape.
As it goes on, by Friday, when
work's in and he's more relaxed
and they've got all the job
done, he's almost a raconteur.
And if you push the right button
on football theory or history,
or-- you know, he doesn't
mind hypotheticals.
He doesn't mind talking history.
He loves it.
He has the largest private--
allegedly-- who knows?
Who could disprove this?
He's alleged to have the largest
private collection of football
books of anybody in the world.
That if he sees a
football book or he
hears about one or a
friend-- somebody, his kids,
or his wife, they know to get
it, add it to the collection.
And he knows more about the
Browns, like Paul Brown,
than his son does, Mike, I
mean, he really is a historian.
He's not that bad at
the end of the week,
but he's terrible for the beat--
but even in his worst days,
as a columnist, you
can write the scene.
So if Belichick's at it again,
being monotone and being
not forthcoming, you can write
that and have some fun with it,
you know.
I mean, as a columnist,
I never went away empty.
Now, Parcells would come out
almost the polar opposite
because he was a raconteur every
day, every day, for four years.
I always said, I always wished
that I had somebody or somebody
had gotten annotated every--
transcribed every press
conference he had, from the day
he signed to the day he left,
it would be a good football--
it would be a bestselling book.
It would be a fabulous book.
All the stuff that
he talked about.
He talked about Broadway.
He talked about horse racing.
He talked about baseball,
talked about Bob Knight,
talked about football.
He was fabulous.
But just the total
opposite of Belichick.
But for a columnist, I
didn't mind Belichick.
But you're absolutely right.
He is the ultimate
nightmare for a beat man.
I've never encountered anybody
close to that in all my years.
No.
AUDIENCE: What is
the biggest rule
change that you
would like to see
in either professional
sports or college?
BOB RYAN: The biggest rule
change I'd like to see
is, you should only
need one foot in
to catch a pass in the
National Football League.
I just can't believe you
should be making people
into Nureyev just
to catch a pass.
That's one foot in college.
It would make life a lot
easier for the referees.
And I just don't
think it's necessary.
I don't see the point.
One foot's in OK in basketball.
One foot's in OK in baseball.
You know, it doesn't
matter in baseball.
You catch the ball or you don't.
But in football,
why do they have
to have two feet as
opposed to college?
I don't understand that.
Baseball, it's not a rule.
Well, it's a DH thing.
Make up your mind, baseball.
When we're playing inter-league
virtually every day now because
of the schedule,
it's preposterous.
I mean, the way it
breaks-- and the way
it's going to go--
they'll keep it.
The Players Association will--
they'll lay under that bus.
They'll never give up the
DH, so give up and do it.
I don't really have enough
knowledge about hockey
to do it.
And basketball.
Rule change?
No, it's not.
It's just interpretation.
I mean, all this emphasis
on flopping and the fines?
Just referee better.
I don't think it's that hard.
I really don't.
I've been watching this
league close up for 45 years.
I don't think it's-- I
think competent referees,
knowing who the players are,
what their proclivities are--
you knew [INAUDIBLE]
was going to flop.
So let him lay there.
You know?
Every once in a great
while, he might get run over
legitimately.
Too bad.
That doesn't make
up for the 500 times
he get away with it, right?
I mean, I don't see
the problem that it's
that big a deal that
it should be a fine
or that referees can't
tell the difference.
I just don't get it.
I don't have a change-- but
I mean, one foot in is--
that really-- and of course--
But I already mentioned
the other thing.
A fumble's a fumble, damn it.
And so I mean, you just
saw one the other day.
Catch the ball, it
falls down, ball
pops out because
you're at the ground.
Why isn't that a fumble?
Hold the damn ball.
That drives me crazy too.
So it's kind of a
tie in football.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned Parcells
as a great example
of somebody who
gave really good
press conferences.
And the Jets have another
one, but their fortunes
seem to be going in
opposite directions.
So the question really is, is
it just that the Jets had better
players and have
worse players now?
Or has society changed?
Has the glare of the
spotlight on coaches
changed such that it is, in
fact, not possible for a coach
to survive for
five years and yet
be as open and
loquacious as Parcells?
BOB RYAN: Well, the
cycles have diminished.
No question.
I'm trying think-- who is the
longest tenured-- Belichick
has got to be, right?
The longest tenured--
who is second?
Anybody know?
I have no idea.
AUDIENCE: Marvin Lewis.
BOB RYAN: Who is?
One year.
BOB RYAN: Marvin Lewis is
second what, eight or nine?
AUDIENCE: No, one year less.
BOB RYAN: One year less?
He's been there that long?
Wow, I didn't realize that.
AUDIENCE: He was hired
out of Baltimore--
BOB RYAN: All right.
Red Auerbach identified
this, believe it or not,
30 years ago, that
cycles were shortening.
Even then, he saw this coming.
This "you need the new
voice," whatever it is.
Coaches get burned out.
The players tune
you out, et cetera.
But now that's not the reason.
It's the instant
gratification of the owners.
As soon as an
owner-- some owners.
There are these
impetuous owners.
They've spent-- they're a new
breed compared to the old guys.
You know, the Ralph Wilsons
as opposed to the Snyders.
You know, Snyder
comes in, and he's
spent all this money
for the Redskins.
And he wants now.
Ralph Wilson came
into the NFL when
you paid $25,000 as
an entry fee in 1960.
That's what it was.
And dies at 94 several
months ago as the owner
of a-- sitting on a goldmine.
But it look 54 years for that
goldmine to accumulate for him.
But other guys come in, and
they want instant gratification.
And especially if someone
has an immediate success,
they say, why can't we have it?
How come he has it?
And that's true in football,
baseball, basketball.
It's so true in all of them.
There's no question.
That's the big change.
It's not so much
that the players
are tuning out the coaches.
So coaches are casualties.
They don't get it--
they become casualties
with some of these
impetuous owners.
And if there's a majority of
those kind of new breed owners,
if you will-- nouveau riche--
whether it's from technology
or whatever it's from, then you
get these coaching casualties.
Say this town.
I mean, you really should
applaud the Celtics ownership,
because Doc Rivers lost 18
games in a row in 2006--
or that team did.
Team lost 18 in a row
in the 2006-2007 season.
Now, there were
mitigating circumstances
that I think we--
the press knew.
Pierce was hurt.
Missed most of them.
They would have won a few with
him, but they lost 18 in a row.
Doc didn't go anywhere.
He was around the next year
to win a championship, thanks
to Danny's manipulations
on that draft day.
These people have shown
remarkable patience I think,
in the long way, and
they believe in Danny.
So I applaud them.
But that's it to me.
It's very simple.
They're just impetuous,
impetuous owners.
I mean, they have
huge investments.
And some of them have
[? debt ?] service.
And they really have
strong concerns.
And the coaches-- [INAUDIBLE].
It's easier to fire one
coach than fill in a blank.
Twelve players in
basketball, 18 in hockey.
Or 23, whatever the roster is.
53 in football and baseball 25.
So that's what they do.
AUDIENCE: On the
topic of the Celtics,
you covered them day-to-day
during a pretty great time
to be doing that
I would imagine.
Could you talk a
little bit about how
the Celtics' relationship
with this city
has transformed over
the last 20 years
or so as it's been
more up and down
and they haven't been that
consistently great team
that they were?
And one quick follow up.
Where do you think that my
favorite player, Paul Pierce,
ranks in the history
of Celtics' greats?
BOB RYAN: I think I've been
here long enough to size
up the ongoing dynamics, OK?
It was, up until a very, very
recent time, the last decade
but even more recently, the
Red Sox were number one.
And then we could start--
and everybody else
was fighting for the two,
three, and four spots.
And in the winter, it
was always a Bruins town.
And the only time the Celtics
reigned supreme, ultimately,
was during the Bird era.
Even during the
Havlicek-Cowens era,
that was the big bad Bruins
they were up against.
And they weren't winning
that battle at all,
even though they won
two championships.
The Bruins did as
well in that era.
And so now, the
Patriots are number one,
and whether the Red Sox are one
or two is a subject of debate.
But who can argue that
the consuming passion now,
number one overall
is the Patriots?
And that's an amazing
transformation
because in 1993, when Parcells
came, they were fourth
and so distant a fourth,
it wasn't even an argument.
But in the winter,
let's be honest,
it's a hockey town at the core.
It's still the greatest
hockey town in America.
Strong high school hockey,
the college situation,
the ability to have a Beanpot.
No other city could have one.
To have those four schools
within three mile radius
play that tournament.
There's no other city
that comes close to that.
But we are a hockey culture
in the winter still.
We've never been a pure
basketball culture.
Never.
In the Russell era, they were
lucky to draw 7,000 to 8,000
a night in the regular season.
And then they would fill
the house in the playoffs.
And then in the
Cowens-Havlicek era,
they maybe got it up
to 12,000, 13,000,
but never consistently sold out.
Bird era, yes, they reigned
supreme thanks to Larry.
And now they've fallen back.
I saw a survey the other day.
What's your favorite team?
And Patriots were one, Red Sox
were two, Bruins were three,
and the Celtics had 6%.
That make sense to me.
I'm a basketball guy,
though it pained me.
I write about this in the book.
I was an impetuous little
brat in the early '70s.
I was always whining about
the Bruins, believe me,
and now people couldn't
officiate the Celtics.
I mention that.
Paul Pierce.
Well, let's start with this.
I've said this--
the first time I
said it was in 2002 after
that game in Indiana
when he got 40 points
with 20 free throws.
And I said, kids,
don't try this at home.
You know, this is
only one guy can
do-- he is the greatest
individual scoring
machine in Celtics history.
Not the best player.
He's not Bird,
he's not Havlicek.
But definitely the best
guy with the most ability--
varied ability to get
the ball in the basket.
Nobody more than Pierce.
He's a three point shooter.
He's a great driver.
He's a great finisher
on the break.
He has all these
up fakes and tricks
that go right back
to the '50s and '60s.
He and Manu Ginobili are
the two most throwback guys
in the league to
the '50s and '60s
with the modern ability
to shoot threes.
Don't foul them.
He goes to the
line and he fouls.
He was an excellent
rebounder for a guard.
Excellent rebounder.
And he was a terrific player.
We got a Mount
Rushmore of Celtics,
which you can't argue, OK?
Which is Russell, Cousy,
Bird, and Havlicek.
But if you want to
go to a five man,
now the fun starts
because you've
got three candidates
for the fifth,
and he's one of them along
with McHale and Cowens.
And Sam Jones right on
the rail, believe me.
But I'm a big booster
of his in this regard,
and to me I think that's
pretty high praise.
I can't put them on the Rushmore
when Rushmore means four.
You can't get there, but he
might be the next one up.
And I always say
this-- people forget--
Paul Pierce came literally
that close to dying.
If the knife goes
into that chest
that far apart the
other way, he's dead.
And I thought that he came
back so fast from that.
I thought it was--
I was in awe that he
was able to function after
that as well as he did.
And we watched him grow, and I
think he became a real leader.
Now, he had that one horrible
moment in Indianapolis
with the gauze on
the face that looked
like the troops at
Valley Forge that night.
That was-- I don't know what
got over him that night.
I have no idea what
he was thinking about.
That was his one
aberrational moment.
Other than that, I think
he was a great Celtic.
AUDIENCE: So what's
one thing that you
knew was going to happen?
That you called right from
the beginning and then
it didn't happen.
The worst thing that
you've swung and missed on.
BOB RYAN: Well, I
thought when Jim Rice hit
the ball in October 1,
1978, a ball was going out
of the ballpark,
but that was wrong.
So we won't go there.
I don't know.
I really don't.
I mean, they had a player
named Garfield Smith in 1969
that I really
thought my first year
that-- second year, second
year-- that I really thought
was going to be a really,
really good player.
He was a good rebounder.
Turned out to be an utter bust.
And he's immortalized.
He did something that
won't be exceeded.
It can only be matched.
And this is the gospel
truth that he did this.
He had the famous free throw
air ball hat trick in Phoenix.
He missed the rim on all three.
All three.
He was 6 for 31 lifetime
free throw shooting.
You can look it up.
I kind of blew it on him.
But other than that, I'm
just trying to think.
You know, I mean, ball players--
Red Sox players come and you
think some of them are
going to be good and great,
and they don't turn
out to be very good.
Honestly, I'm not trying to--
I don't have an answer to that.
Garfield Smith jumps out at
me, but I was young then.
I developed more perspective.
AUDIENCE: One more
quick question.
So Boston and New
England in general
have so many iconic sports
figures, from Tom Brady
all the way down to
Russell and everybody else.
If you had to pick one person
to represent Boston sports,
who is it?
And why do you
choose Larry Bird?
BOB RYAN: I'm just
trying to think about--
that question is a different
one in the slant to it?
Representing the city, I
might go Havlicek over-- I
might go Havlicek
as a representative.
You know, scrub him up,
bring him home to mother.
No problems.
That kind of thing.
Larry had some rough
edges, though I love Larry.
And Larry grew to love Boston.
But when you stand up there in
front of thousands of people
at City Hall and you utter
the S word in regard to Moses,
you know, that's a little bit
the lack of polish, as we say.
Everybody loved it, of course.
Bobby Orr is still the
most revered figure
in my time in Boston.
As of 50 years I've been
here-- post-date Ted Williams.
That whole other worship of
Ted of the elder generation
is something else, you know?
So in my time, the 50 years
I've been here since I set foot
in BC in 1964, the most
revered athlete I think
is still Bobby Orr.
And rightly so because
he's the greatest hockey
player that ever lived.
Period.
And so there-- and it's just the
fact that he ended at age 30.
Today, if he came along,
that first knee scope
would've been done and
he would've been fine.
But that's true of a
lot of guys in history.
We know that.
But it's very, very true of Orr.
I'd have to settle him.
He never made a
misstep in public.
He represented-- to
this day, he just
exudes class and positivity
and everything else.
AUDIENCE: So him over Tom Brady?
BOB RYAN: Brady's fine.
Brady-- there's nothing-- Brady
hasn't done anything wrong.
I would say that people--
this isn't going outside.
I mean, I don't want
this misinterpreted.
OK?
I mean, I'm going to
have to be very careful.
Somebody's-- I got the good guy
over here and the bad guy over
here telling me don't do this.
But please understand
what I'm saying.
If he hadn't married the
most successful model
in the world-- if
he had married,
if not necessarily
the girl next door,
but a regular person-- he
always dated celebrities.
That was always the case.
That's the only thing.
To some people, that might
put them off a little bit,
you know?
But I mean, other guys
think it's fantastic
that he never dated
anything but celebrities.
His money literally is tip
money in their family account.
It's the discretionary
fund money.
It's all it is.
They can go anywhere
they want in the world.
He can pay for it
out of his-- it
makes him feel good
that he can help out.
You know I'm right.
That must be funny.
And the other thing is,
the houses they build.
It's like Jeter.
What does Jeter need
with that monstrosity
down there, that
they have already
nicknamed St. Jetersburg
in West Coast of Florida.
I don't know.
Anyway, Brady would be
a fine representative.
He always says the right thing.
He's a bright guy.
But I'm going to stick with Orr.
AUDIENCE: A couple of things.
Quarterbacks.
Are they management
or are they labor,
and how much should they be
standing up for the rest?
And this is not a
new topic, right?
I mean, even in the '90s
they had this whole QB club
thing where they tried to
split off from the players
union in terms of
making their own money.
BOB RYAN: So who are you saying
about-- is who management?
AUDIENCE: Quarterbacks.
How much should they
stand with the players,
and how much should
they stand with the team
when it comes to, for
example, negotiations?
BOB RYAN: Well, I used
to kid, and it's probably
a good rule of thumb.
Never trust an owner
any farther than you
can throw the building
or the stadium.
I mean, for the most part.
None of them are
purely altruistic.
They're all in it-- they want
to make some money anymore.
There's no doubt about it.
But some are more willing to
lose more money than others.
You have to sympathize.
Once again, in sports--
in a sport like football,
with the short career
life, the danger of injury,
the idea of, yeah,
your career could
end at any-- look
what happened Sunday.
Ridley and Mayo out for
the year on one play.
Not cumulative.
You have to have some
sympathy for the players.
The pendulum-- this is so
analogous to real life labor
management going back to Samuel
Gompers and John L. Lewis
and the whole labor
movement in America
going back to the late
19th century and Sinclair
Lewis and the whole thing.
I mean, you had the
management, and you
had the oppressed workers.
I had to laugh when
Marvin Miller did
say, as he did say
when he took over,
that the baseball writers were
the most oppressed workers he
had ever represented.
And he was an economist
who represented
all kinds of union people.
But remember this.
Marvin Miller took over in 1966.
You know what the--
show of hands.
Anybody know?
What do you think the minimum
salary in baseball was in 1966?
Minimum salary by the virtue
of their collective bargaining
agreement.
1966.
We had indoor
plumbing, remember.
Color TV.
The whole bit.
AUDIENCE: $50?
BOB RYAN: $6,000.
And they had, of
course, no free agency.
No rights.
The reserve clause
bound them forever.
The whole thing.
Things had to improve.
It was arbitration that did it.
It was Peter Seitz
the arbitrator
that overturned the
Messersmith case.
That's the big seminal moment
that changed everything.
As much as Marvin Miller was a
strident defender of the union
rights, that arbitrator Peter
Seitz is the one who actually
is the person that they
should all be thanking today
for the way the world is now.
So owners didn't
do it willingly.
They fought every change
every step of the way.
There were two guys--
believe it or not,
they were very interesting
because they're very distinctly
different out there,
outsides people.
The two owners who were so
far away from their mainstream
of all other owners
during their time,
and they did
overlap to a degree.
Bill Veeck and Charlie Finley,
both of whom at different times
advocated total free
agency, thinking
that it would all settle itself.
OK, and that was,
oh my god, aghast.
They were always ahead of their
time and always iconoclastic.
So by and large, you've
got to go players.
Yeah.
Because there's an awful lot
owners that still-- I mean,
it's just the
nature of the beast.
That's all.
AUDIENCE: Why didn't
you list Wellington Mara
in that list of
owners as the guy who
said, "We're going to share
all revenue nationally
in our sport as opposed
to other sports?"
BOB RYAN: What about
Wellington Mara?
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: As an owner who is
so different from the rest.
BOB RYAN: Well,
the Mara family is
invested in football
for eight decades.
OK?
Tim Mara got the team
back in the '30s.
It's like the Rooneys.
The Rooneys are the dynasty.
Whether or not Art
Rooney actually
won the team in a poker game is
part of the apocryphal story.
It wasn't quite that, but it
was something close to that.
And now the Rooneys
are still there.
His grandsons are
still running the team.
There's some wonderful owners--
the Griffiths in baseball
were the last people I remember
who-- well, I don't know.
It's true of Rooney and Mara.
They make their
living from the team
as opposed to-- the Griffiths
were the last ones in baseball.
And of course, they
were always accused
of being penny
pinching, you know.
But I think the
Maras are considered
to be excellent
owners as owners go.
AUDIENCE: I guess the
point was that, I think
he was the one who
said that we're
going to share national revenue,
which was against, for example,
what baseball did and perhaps
as the single decision that
causes the success of football.
The flat salary cap and
shared national revenue on TV.
BOB RYAN: I mean, I
think the Maras are
high on the list of good--
I think Kraft-- hey,
you know-- I think Kraft
has by and large been
a great owner for the fans.
I'm well aware of
his business issues.
I know his litigation forever.
I'm well aware of all that.
And I know he has
a tremendous ego.
And I know he wants to
walk down the street
and have people say,
hi, Mr. Kraft, thank you
so much for everything you've
done for us and all that.
He does.
I know he does.
But he's been a pretty
damn good owner.
And he got that stadium built.
And yeah, it wasn't completely
without the help of the public,
but it wasn't as much
public aid as other stadiums
and other arenas
in other cities.
By and large,
we're pretty lucky.
But in general terms, look,
this is a capitalist society.
We have a system in which the
ownership owns and the labor
works, but still
owners will get away
with everything they
can get away with.
And if they weren't forced
into it kicking and screaming
at times.
Now, watch out for the
next-- in two years
when the NBA association
can opt out of the agreement
now that they've got this
whopping new TV contract.
And if the owners
didn't realize that was
going to be a byproduct of this,
then they are rather foolish.
But I'm sure they do.
So be prepared for a delay
in the start of the 2016-17
season, I think.
I'm telling you right now,
[INAUDIBLE] we know that.
Anybody else?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I do want to get your
opinion on the Boston Olympics.
BOB RYAN: OK, good.
I love the Olympics.
I think Boston would
be a tremendous site.
I can just imagine--
what you need
for a successful Olympics,
over and above the venues,
is gathering places
and places for people
to go in the off hours.
Picture the Commonwealth
Mall from Kenmore Square
up to the Garden as people from
all over the world strolling.
Maybe there'd be
kiosks, whatever.
Temporary kiosks,
it would have to be.
Picture City Hall Plaza.
Picture the waterfront as
it is getting more and more
transformed into something
really nice by 2024.
There's lots-- I think
it'd be fantastic.
Then take a trip to
Beijing or Athens
and look at the stadium
sitting there doing nothing.
And ask Athens how
they feel about it now.
Ask Beijing.
I mean, if Bill Gates
or Warren Buffett
wants to write a check for
us for the billions that
would take, OK.
But the logistics are daunting.
I can't believe what
I'm hearing from people.
They have to build a stadium.
They're not going
to use Foxborough.
They have to build--
where would they put--
and what happens afterward?
The Patriots aren't
moving there.
Who's going to play there?
The Revolution?
No.
The Red Sox?
Eastie versus Southie
on Thanksgiving Day?
Is that it?
What?
Here's the things
that always happen.
The Velodrome sits
there and nobody
knows what to do
with the Velodrome.
The swimming pool is oversized
and gigantic, sits there,
and nobody knows what to
do with the swimming pool.
The Chinese don't even know
what to do with the stadium.
The birds nest stadium.
They don't having to do with it.
The reality-- look at what's
happening with the Winter
Olympics.
We have two autocratic
countries left.
Oslo opted out.
We've got Kazakhstan,
and we've got Beijing.
Winter Olympics in Beijing.
They're talking about
hundreds of miles
away for skiing
events and everything.
But they seem to be
the only countries now
that are willing to
absorb all the costs
and do what they have to do.
I mean, they displaced
how many hundreds
of thousands of
people in Beijing?
We'll never know.
I love being there,
but I always--
but I think it's preposterous.
I don't know what they
are smoking or drinking
or-- I have no idea
if they've ever
really thought this out fully.
This guy John [INAUDIBLE].
And also, do you like the
idea that the guy that's
the [? protagonist ?] just
happens to be in construction?
I mean, seriously.
I mean, this isn't even--
he's not hiding anything.
He's this construction guy.
He would profit
enormously from this.
No.
The answer is no.
OK?
No.
And I'm worried about the
future of the Olympics
because the 2022 thing is scary.
That that's all we've got left,
and nobody-- I was hoping Oslo
would say yes, but they're
smart people and they said no.
And it may have to
just run its course,
the Olympics as we know it.
But I do love them.
I would recommend if you can get
to Rio, it's an amazing take.
I love the take, as we say.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: This will be the
last one from me, I promise.
So I wrote an op
piece about-- we
were putting up a
statue for Bill Russell.
And it talked a lot about the
history of racism in Boston
and how that has
affected the NBA.
And you were a huge
advocate for the NBA
back in the day when they
couldn't fill the house up
because of the Bruins who were
in large part a white team.
Do you think that
racism has played
that kind of pivotal role?
What's your opinion
on that and how
it's affected the history and
the future of the NBA here
in Boston?
BOB RYAN: There was no question
that when Dave Cowens came,
suddenly sprung up a fan base
that had not patronized them.
Spent money to see them.
He certainly became a
very popular player,
and I don't think
there's any accident
that the Celtics started to
acquire a sounder, stronger,
wider fanbase because the
new exciting player happened
to be white.
Ridiculous.
I don't think it's any
accident that-- and I remember,
I actually wrote this once about
the-- in the Bird-McHale era,
that the greatest
cheers in the building
are when McHale blocks the
shot of a big black star,
specifically Dr. J. It's
foolish to deny that impulse.
I think we've evolved
and we're much better.
The Red Sox thing, the
history is shameful.
The Yawkey history is shameful.
And right into the
'70s, the players
who will tell you how much they
did not like Boston-- Reggie
Smith was the most
outspoken one of all.
It got better and better.
And Mo Vaughan would tell
you totally the opposite
now, because he came up in the
'80s-- in the '90s, excuse me.
We've evolved to a degree.
The whole busing thing.
Boston's national
image was horrible.
There were players,
and there may still
be some left for all I
know, who had things written
in their contract in baseball
they couldn't be traded here.
This was one of the cities
they didn't want to come to,
black players.
But the NBA being-- the
composition of the NBA being
whatever percentage it is black
is a whole different matter
now.
Everybody's is used to
the idea that the odds are
that 8 or 9 or 10 of the players
on the court at any given time
are going to be black.
And people are used to
that who love basketball.
But we had a bad history
here, no question about it.
The Red Sox were shameful.
We all know the history.
The last black player and all
the other stuff I just cited.
But I'm sure it affected people.
But I think this fortunately
younger generation did not
bring-- did not carry over
the prejudices of their elders
here.
I think that was-- I
remember going back
to the book, "The
Greening of America."
That book was very popular.
It talked about how the younger
generation would evolve.
And I think, in that
case, in this city,
racial relations have evolved
better because the younger
generation shed the
prejudices of their parents.
Just an observation.
AUDIENCE: On the
racism thing, recently
with the Clippers
and actually more
interestingly the Hawks,
what's going on here?
Especially for the
Hawks, for what
seemed like a somewhat racist
but somewhat innocuous thing,
he just quietly disappeared.
I mean, has the pendulum swung
all the way to the other side
where now--
BOB RYAN: Well, in general
terms, a lot of pendulum
has swung a long way.
Things that could be said
and written 25 years ago,
you can't do it now.
You cannot do it.
I'll give you an example--
Oh, the Hawks thing.
We're talking about
the owner saying
that they-- the
black fans-- they
wanted a season ticket
holding white population
because the black fans
don't buy season tickets.
And they scared
away the white fans.
And the music scared
I mean, oh my God, you know.
That was hard to read.
It really was.
Accompanied by the
scouting report.
Talking about Luol
Deng that there's
too much African in this game.
Oh boy.
Just when you think
you're beyond all this,
this thing rears its head.
My opinion on
Atlanta, by the way,
is that isn't the real issue.
The issue is that it's
just a lousy sports town.
And they've been there 46
years, and they've never
gotten to the finals.
And people are just never come
and adopted that team the way
they could or should.
I was going to say
something about-- oh, hell,
I forgot about it.
I'm sorry.
I was going to play off that.
Oh, yeah, 25 years ago or more.
30, I don't know.
Maybe more.
I was writing a piece that was
common to-- these things were
very common.
And I wrote one for
Inside Sport magazine.
And it was about the
all-black black team,
the all-white white team,
the all-black white team,
and the all-white black team.
Guys who played-- the guys
who have the funkiest games,
the all-black black team.
The all white team, guys who
had the whitest game, and then
the crossover players.
You couldn't print that now.
You could not get
that in print now.
Nobody-- you could not do it.
The players all got it.
They always got it.
It's still truth in the NBA
that the white man's disease
is the best ongoing
joke in the NBA.
Woe be to the black player who
has the white man's disease.
He's going to get razzed by
his team forever, et cetera.
But the public-- but you can't
even do that anymore and not
have some special interest
group jumping all over you.
You can't even do that anymore,
even though the league is
perfectly tuned to the
idea that the NBA is
the only element--
maybe not the only,
but one of the most prominent
areas of our society
where the fact of the matter
is that the white man is judged
to be inferior by definition
and has to prove himself.
And everybody in the league
knows it at every level,
but you can't say that
in public anymore.
So yeah.
We've gone-- we're in such
a PC frightening world,
and humorless world, and
special interest world.
And I speak as a left of
center person, trust me,
but I get a little
bit frustrated.
I mean, with some
of this nonsense.
I couldn't write that
story today, it's too bad.
It was a pretty good story.
Well, we've gone
through our hour.
I am not going anywhere.
You may have to.
So I mean, I've
got plenty of time
if anybody wants to linger.
But thank you for coming.
I really appreciate it.
Let me just say one
thing about the book.
Nobody asked me a
question, so I'm
going to give you my little--
what I hope you take away
from the book is that I
am somebody who was almost
programmed to do what I did
by virtue of my background.
And that I enjoyed it
and I still like it.
And though you hear
about how many writers
get jaded and cynical and
they don't care about who
wins and loses and
they only write
about people and all that
stuff, I'm not that guy.
And I still love the
sports, the games.
People talk about
writing about people.
Well, we wouldn't care
about these people
if it weren't for the game.
The core of it is that all
these people are involved
in playing a game, no
matter what the game is.
And so I just would try
to reflect that I'm really
grateful and happy and
lucky that I got to do it.
And I hope I can share
that enthusiasm with you
throughout by reading the book.
So thank you very much for
your attention and coming
and thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]